Er ist jung, er hat studiert, aber
er verkauft sich für billiges Geld:
eine Kampagne gegen Lohndumping.
Die Idee stammt von
diesen beiden Geschäftspartnern.
Es war der Slogan gegen
Kreativ-Prostitution.
Also, wir wollen einfach verhindern, dass
die Leute sich unter Wert verkaufen.
Arbeiten zu Niedriglöhnen
in der Kreativbranche –
damit haben sie auch
schon Erfahrung gemacht.
Deshalb gründeten sie
ihre Vermittlungsagentur für Kreative.
Es gibt auf der einen Seite die Entwicklung,
dass Leute immer mehr ausgebeutet werden,
es gibt Plattformen, wo man dann… wo
100 Leute irgendwie ein Logo designen,
und nur der Gewinner
erhält dann Geld dafür.
Das sehen wir einfach als
absolute Ausbeutung.
Die Berliner Kreativbranche trifft
sich in solchen hippen Workspaces:
Web-Designer, Texter, Fotografen.
Doch manche von ihnen müssen mit
Honoraren auf
Sozialhilfeniveau auskommen:
knapp 1000 Euro im Monat.
In ihrem Firmenvideo zeigen
die Jobvermittler,
wie sie Arbeitgeber und
Arbeitnehmer zusammenbringen.
Sie vermitteln die Kreativen
zu einem festen Tagessatz.
Viele sagen ja immer: 300 Euro
als Tagessatz, das klingt zu viel.
Das ist ganz normal für Leute, die mit
Freelancen nichts zu tun haben.
Aber wenn man das mal
hoch- und runterrechnet,
kommt man halt schnell darauf, dass
man da keine Rente von zahlen kann,
dass man da nichts davon
zurücklegen kann.
Esther Schaarhüls ist Grafikdesignerin.
Sie wurde von den beiden an
eine Werbeagentur vermittelt.
Dafür erhalten sie zehn Prozent
Provision von ihrem Honorar.
Dann ging das eigentlich relativ schnell,
also, ich glaub, innerhalb von zwei Tagen
hat die erste Agentur angerufen und
dann eine Woche später die nächste,
und mittlerweile gibt es auch Agenturen,
die dann auch wiederkommen.
Berlin: ein Eldorado für die
internationale Kreativszene.
Doch für jeden Dritten reicht
das Geld kaum zum Leben.
Statt alleine zu Hause zu sitzen,
arbeitet Esther Schaarhüls
lieber zusammen mit
anderen Selbstständigen.
Hier findet sie Anregungen, Kontakte
und manchmal auch neue Jobs.
Ihr Tagessatz erscheint hoch –
auf den ersten Blick.
Also, theoretisch fängt [es] bei 450 an,
450, 500 Euro. Und wie oft?
Also, es kommt sehr drauf an:
Im Sommer ist es ganz oft so,
dass man öfter mal gebucht wird, aber
dann heißt es jetzt auch nicht jeden Tag,
sondern dass es dann vielleicht ein-,
zweimal im Monat,
dann ist aber auch wieder
zwei Monate nichts.
Weltweit wächst der Markt
für die kreative Bohème.
Sie sind jung, wollen unabhängig sein.
Doch über die Schattenseiten
sprechen sie ungern.
Nach jedem Auftrag
wartet die Ungewissheit.
Sie sind gewerkschaftlich
nicht organisiert.
Es fehlen Tarifabschlüsse. Ihre schöne heile
Welt belächeln manche mit Zynismus.
Tagessatz? Hast du gerade
Tagessatz gesagt?
Wow, ehrlich gesagt, in der Kategorie
denke ich gar nicht.
Du kriegst genug Geld, damit du nicht
verhungerst, und das ist es dann auch.
Und dann arbeitest du irgendwie
zwischen acht und 16 Stunden
und manchmal auch 20, manchmal
auch 24, das ist aber selten.
Aber in Tagessätzen kannst
du nicht rechnen.
Aber die Grafik-Designerin hat
für sich dazugelernt.
Auf Lohndumping lässt sie sich
heute nicht mehr ein.
Da muss man dann, auch um seine eigene
Energie und auch um sein eigenen …
dass man auch seine Unkosten hat,
um das zu schützen,
muss man einfach auch hingehen
und Grenzen setzen.
In ganz Deutschland arbeiten 1,5 Millionen
Menschen in der Kreativbranche.
Aber anders als Esther Schaarhüls
schaffen es die meisten nicht,
den Wert ihrer Arbeit auch durchzusetzen.